we begin in Britain where the Supreme
Court has ruled that Prime Minister
Boris Johnson suspension of Parliament
was unlawful the decision means
lawmakers can reassemble quote as soon
as possible which would deal a hammer
blow to Johnson's plans for taking
Britain out of the year the unanimous
verdict found that the suspension
preventive Parliament from doing its job
without reasonable justification Supreme
Court head a Brenda Hale had this to say
Parliament has not been probed this is
the unanimous judgment of all eleven
justices it is for Parliament and in
particular speaker and the Lord speaker
to decide what to do next unless there
is some parliamentary rule of which we
are unaware they can take immediate
steps to enable each house to meet as
soon as possible it is not clear to us
that any step is needed from the Prime
Minister but if it is the court is
pleased that his counsel have told the
court that he will take all necessary
steps to comply with the terms of any
declaration made by this Court
so that was a presiding a judge of the
Supreme Court of Brenda hey let's now go
straight to the Supreme Court in London
where our correspondent Charlotte Potts
is standing by Charlotte a unanimous
decision from the eleven judges tell us
more about what was said and what this
means what a momentous and historic
ruling here in the United Kingdom today
we have to remind ourselves this was a
power struggle between the executive the
legislative and the judicial basically
Boris Johnson overstepping his powers as
Prime Minister as the Supreme Court just
ruled in Prague in Parliament and
sending them on this force break and the
Supreme Court with lady Hale their
presiding as the Chief Justice ruled
that it was not a normal prorogation not
a normal short prorogation but a longer
one that kept Parliament from
debating mad
especially of course brexit related at
this crucial time in UK history so what
we are seeing right now is the first
reactions coming in to this momentous
ruling and those are for example from
John Burke Oh the Speaker of Parliament
had said that Parliament should now
reconvene immediately so that means that
MPs will be assembling probably tomorrow
and start debating all matters brexit
again and we've also heard from the
Labour opposition calls for the prime
minister to resign at when this decision
when this ruling came out here at the
Supreme Court in London we've urged
tremendous cheers from demonstrators who
had assembled here despite the rain this
morning calling for Johnson to resign
and celebrating a victory for while
democracy and for the strengthening of
Parliament so cheers from some but a
huge setback for Boris Johnson do we
know what this means for him and how is
really to react well of course this is a
an absolute blow for Boris Johnson he
right now is in New York at the UN
General Assembly he has it's about 6:00
a.m. there so somebody will have woken
him up by now or he has followed this of
course from his hotel room and it is a
huge blow we are the pressure will mount
on him to resign because essentially
what this ruling means is that he miss
let the Queen in advising her to send
Parliament on break that he was lying to
the Queen and giving that his motivation
was to pass silence Parliament and of
course that doesn't go down well here in
Great Britain so we will see strong
reactions there from the opposition
party and of course this comes this is a
huge humiliation for Boris Johnson who
is due to hold his first big speech at
the UN General Assembly tonight in front
of world leaders and all the European
leaders that he is negotiating at the
moment a new deal for the UK to leave
the European Union with so a huge
humiliation there and will probably most
likely see a well Boris Johnson
that has to kind of take this ruling in
in the course of the day in New York
so of course reactions coming in a thick
and fast we've just heard the leader of
the opposition Labour Party Jeremy
Corbyn has called on Boris Johnson to
resign and of course Boris Johnson had
never indicated that he would resign
even if he faced a setback
so not Dennis child what happens next
you mentioned the Speaker of Parliament
John Bercow saying that the Parliament
can resume as soon as possible
exactly so we have to reiterate Boris
Johnson has said of course he will
follow this ruling from the Supreme
Court here said that last night but that
he has no intention to resign what we
will see now is Parliament reconvening
immediately that could be in the course
of the day tomorrow the Labour
opposition party is just finishing its
party conference in the course of the
day tomorrow so we can see Parliament
reconvene and then asking Boris Johnson
to release documents on all matters
proceed on his brexit strategy on how he
was planning to to force the European
Union into giving him a new deal and
what he was planning in case of a No
Deal scenario so we will see a lot of
pressure there on Boris Johnson and then
of course as you mentioned the news that
the Labour Party now wants him to resign
and we will have to see how that plays
out because he of course is holding his
seat in Downing Street and he is not
planning on giving that up
and he shot before we let you go just
tell us a little bit more about the
significance of this historic ruling
today for brexit what does it mean for
the actual decision that Boris Johnson
always said that was doing die he would
leave the Britain in Britain out of the
European Union by the 31st of October
well I think it becomes more likely that
we will see another extension to brexit
because that is what Parliament decided
should happen that Boris Johnson should
go back to the European Union and ask
for another extension beyond October
31st this ruling from Parliament
majority of MPs voted for that became
law a couple of weeks ago before
Parliament was suspended and now with
the strengthening
of the power of Parliament it definitely
seems like Boris Johnson will have to
follow this ruling and that there is no
way out for him because this really
shifted the power away from him away
from the executive and strengths in
Parliament DG abuse Charlotte Potts
outside the Supreme Court in London
thank you very much for your reporting
from there